mit oder ohne kabel sodann und herz
bekommt bei einem neuen lied oh ja ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir so
halbwegs kann man so sagen also ich weiß
ja was mitbekommen habt ich habe
vorgestern das haben wir heute freitag
noch genau
am mittwoch bin ich wieder da kommen aus
hamburg wenn denn der bahn hier in die
richtung gefahren und habe meinem
rucksack drin vergessen oder wurde mir
klar ich habe keinen plan auf jeden fall
war plötzlich weg und seitdem habe ich
halt in der ganzen zeit bis jetzt mein
rucksack versucht wieder zu bekommen und
hatte überhaupt website youtube videos
zu drehen weil da halt alles mögliche
drin immer von mir ein bisschen scheinst
du jemand foto von meinem rucksack wenn
ihr denn irgendwo in köln findet sag mir
bescheid schreibt über instagram 30 alex
w und bitte auch wirklich nur wenn es
ernst meint danke auf jeden fall können
wir das jetzt ein bisschen beiseite
schieben weil heute gibt es ein neues
video endlich wieder wenn wir das leucht
drei tage pause gehabt und zwar ist mir
aufgefallen der letzte neue fast food
trends testen testvideo wenn sie
verstehen was ich meine ist schon ein
bisschen länger her
ich habe geschaut er gibt es ja wieder
was neues und es gibt ein paar neue
sachen allerdings bin ich dann auf die
idee gekommen mit juni zusammen wir
machen heute mal also wir testen alle
macstories weil alle die es gerade gibt
habe ich noch nie probiert und kann man
ein video ausmachen haben uns gedacht
das gibts heute wir fahren jetzt los das
gute ist gerade wurde mir mein
ersatzschlüssel geliefert hier weil man
autoschlüssel war auch im rucksack
wir können also ich muss sagen ich war
schon wird
sehr lange nicht mehr bei diesen
mcdonald's sind bestimmt schon zwei
monate oder so ganz schön lang
ich bin da halt immer nur für videos ist
halt so brauchen wir wieder alle wieder
dieses jahr mal richtig aber letztes
jahr ein bisschen verpackt dass wir
wieder irgendwie so für 200 euro pommes
kaufen und ein monopoly ausmachen könnte
man machen oder 8000 exemplare kassel
und hier habe ich irgendwann meinen
rucksack verloren und rein mit auto was
gibt es neues thema
ok
das ist negativ
ich hätte gerne einmal alle macstories
geht es alle einmal ja genau jedes
einzelne
[Musik]
schoko ja genau
sie kommen meist nicht mit wechsel ohne
kam es dann okay danke das ist wirklich
der beste der ist so freundlich
ich bestelle irgendwie immer bei dem
aber besser man wirklich also hier
schöne grüße an sich halten will dann
gehört noch eine leinwand
ach guck mal da ist es danke ich gehöre
jetzt kommen wir sie doch richtig gut
aus ist das alles die gleiche verpackung
sind ja garnicht loches drauf als ich
das los gekauft habe damals war auch gar
nicht da waren auch gar nicht die drauf
also ich muss sagen ein bisschen
bisschen nicht ein bisschen so ich bin
nicht so ganz überzeugt weil das half
ihr stück sind dann setzen wir uns auch
schon den einzigen vorteil den wir hier
raus jetzt genießen ich habe keines
dieser sorten bis jetzt jemals in atem
das ist ja langweilig das habe ich
natürlich schon probiert das ist ja
dieses martins
aber ich habe schon länger nicht mehr
gegessen und das angebaute war das war
mit schokosoße es plötzlich dann lass
uns einfach mal damit anfangen
auch wenn wir heute nur vier produkte
haben ich werde trotzdem wie bei den
essens videos auch punkte verteilen und
mich schauen wir was dann im endeffekt
am besten abschneidet ist ja eigentlich
am besten so gut das kann ich mit
schokolade aber heute ganz schön weit es
ist kalt
alex ist als niemand absolut niemand
alex kalt
sony habe ich vergessen zu sagen ich
lasse das noch kurz außer wertung weil
ich bin nicht sicher bin ob das eine 10
ist weil ich das halt schon seit kind an
immer essen oder öffnung von gegessen
haben oder wenn ich heute einfach zu
lernen ist es dass deswegen machen wir
mal hier wird weiter
hast du plan hat das ist sieht aus wie
nüsse oder ich weiß das haben wir auch
nicht wie bei einfach gesagt einmal alle
es ist trommelwirbel tricks karamell
hast du schon mal probiert man gibt es
das verlange ich weiß es nicht erkenne
ich mir jetzt gar nicht so aus hat sich
auf jeden fall kann ich möchte eins zu
eins nicht dieses tricks eis weißt du
dass man überall kaufen können also auch
nichts besonderes in schriftform ihr
sieben punkte dass ihr kriegt dann von
mir 9
das heißt wir haben bis jetzt platz eins
und platz zwei und jetzt kommen wir hier
noch zu sneakers nie was immer das war's
nix aktuell jetzt bin ich raus weil hier
waren müsste drin leute sorry ich nehme
alles zurück das schmeckt wie snickers
eis ich habe das gerade im kopf des
lesers alles was man im supermarkt
kaufen kann also jetzt nicht so
besonders
deswegen sieben von zehn ist absolut
korrekt und jetzt kommen wir wohl als
nächstes zum tricksen kann man das ziel
auch die tricks aus
da haben wir schon mal eineinhalb punkte
vergeben
nein familie gibt keine halben punkt
gibt es nicht bisher sicher das kann man
ja nicht mal ein auge zudrücken wenn
alle sieht ja dann gibt es auch hier
neun punkten ist jetzt keine zehn und
dann jetzt zum schluss und zwar haben
wir hier marshmallow blaubeere oder so
was ähnliches oder so ist das doch da
bin ich jetzt mal gespannt was mich kurz
noch den namen mac flori marshmallow
blueberry wie es gesagt habe da könnte
jemand aus ihr könnt gerne euer
lieblings eis in die kommentare
schreiben
eventuell ja auf 1 was ist jetzt hier
gar nicht gab nehmen wir mal ein richtig
dicken löffel hier schon mit blauer hose
juli in der film action
[Musik]
eben die pasta gar nichts zusammen die
marge mindestens so richtig weich das
passt gar nicht zum eis weist das tut
mir leid es war auf jeden fall am
meisten aus jetzt nicht mehr
aber es schmeckt am wenigsten eine
chance tricks noch von 10 kann man
nichts machen ich muss sagen so das war
jetzt in essen ist es da wenn ich nicht
so bin ich ein bisschen enttäuscht
darüber
ich habe es mir irgendwie spektakulärer
vorgestellt tut mir leid was willst du
machen das war's mehr kann ich dazu
nicht sagen
ich hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
schreibt wir mal weitere produkte von
denen ich alle sorten testen und die
kommentare
ansonsten wenn irgendwas vom rucksack
hört schreibt mir bei instagram alex w
und immer clubs werden jetzt alle von
uns beiden zusammen
ein spaß wir sehen uns morgen um 20 uhr
ja da gibt es ein neues airports video
wollte mich sehr darauf euch das zu
zeigen haut wahlen